[Musique]
piron délice partait parfois en voyage
sans prévenir personne
un jour son navire fut pris dans une
tempête
celle ci dure et au point qu elle
plongea les membres de l'équipage dans
la dépression le philosophe leur montra
alors un petit cochon qui mange est avec
une grande imperturbable it et malgré le
danger la bête d'ordinaire méprisés et
ai donc dans ces circonstances
exceptionnelles
un modèle d'atara xi pour l'homme cette
anecdote nous invite à réfléchir à la
manière dont l'être humain se rapporte à
l'animal l'homme et lettres vivants
appartenant à l'espèce homo sapiens il
est principalement caractérisé par un la
station verticale de la
multifonctionnalité de la mme13 le
développement considérable du cerveau et
4 la communication par le langage
articulé un animal est un être vivant
qui se distingue des autres végétaux par
un la mobilité de la sensibilité
3 la représentation et 4 l'incapacité de
se nourrir directement d'éléments
inorganiques la distinction des deux
termes est importante pour l'être humain
car il ne semble pas vouloir qu'on les
confonde avec l'animal il est plutôt
rare que l'homme voit en une bête un
modèle positif
au contraire les animaux sont souvent ça
boue sur le sud
ce que fait l'animal c'est ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire sa saleté son ignorance
et son impulsivité sont indignes d'un
être humain
ne dit on pas pour la blâmer d'une
personne stupide grossière ou brutale
qu'elle est un animal ne se serre ton
pas du même mot bête en tant que nom
commun pour désigner l'animal et en tant
qu'adulte tiff pour qualifier un homme
qui manque d'intelligence une pléthore
d'indicés laissent à penser que l'être
humain se voit lui même avant tout comme
n'étant pas un animal pourquoi donc
paraît-il temps tenir à la distinction
il ne faut néanmoins pas s'arrêter à ce
constat ainsi que le suggère piron
délice lorsqu'il invite à s'inspirer de
la tranquillité d'un petit cochon la
différence avec l'animal est elle
véritablement aussi radicale que l'homme
ne le pense si tel n'était pas le cas
alors cela signifierait qu'il y aurait
en réalité de l'animal en l'homme
comment dès lors comprendre le rapport
de l'humanité à l'animalité
dans quelle mesure l'homme dit fertile
vraiment de l'animal si l'homme semble
se définir lui même comme un être vivant
radicalement supérieur à l'animal il ne
peut cependant pas nié la part
d'animalité qui le caractérise mais
cette en dépassant la nuit mal qui est
en lui que l'être humain accomplirait
son humanité
l'homme tient à la distinction de
l'humanité et de l'animalité parce qu'il
se situe lui même au sommet de la
hiérarchie du vivant force est de
constater tout d'abord que l'être humain
a acquis une position dominante par
rapport aux animaux qu'ils soient
sauvages destinés à l'élevage ou
domestiques
ils sont à la merci de l'homme cela n'a
certes pas toujours été le cas
les humains sont restés de faibles
créatures craintive pendant 2 millions
d'années ils ont commencé à affronter
les prédateurs et à s'attaquer à du gros
gibier il y a quatre cent mille ans puis
ils se sont hissés au sommet de la
chaîne alimentaire
il y a seulement cent mille ans avec
l'essor de l'espèce sapiens mais la
domination humaine relève est
aujourd'hui de l'oppression juge les
critiques
peter singer pointe notamment du doigt
la manière dont les hommes réifie les
bêtes pour en faire de simples outils de
recherche les chercheurs considèrent je
cite les animaux sur lesquels portent
leurs expériences écrit-il comme des
pièces d'équipement comme des outils de
laboratoire plutôt que comme des êtres
vivants et souffrant la libération
animale
c'est à cause de la distinction radicale
de l'humanité et de l'animalité estime
le philosophe que l'expérimentation
animale a pu devenir une véritable
industrie dans les pays développés la
domination de l'homme déterminerait donc
sa relation aux bêtes
l'iniquité du rapport de force
confirmerait l'idée de l'infériorité
animal mais on peut imaginer cela n'est
pas rare que la théorie soit venu à la
rescousse des faits les êtres humains
ont tendance à essentialiser leur propre
hiérarchie a légitimé par le discours
la domination et la soumission comment
ne pas craindre que ce mécanisme
idéologique ne biaise également la
réflexion sur l'animal lorsque sont
apparus dans l'europe du xviie siècle
les premiers automates articulé on les
compare à des bêtes
celles ci ne sont in fine et comme les
machines résonnait ton que des
combinaisons de pièces formant des
rouages sans conscience ni penser des
cartes adhèrent à cette réduction de
l'animal à cette dimension mécanique
dans sa lettre au marquis de newcastle
il explique le comportement animal
entièrement par l'instinct soit un
ensemble de mécanismes qui s'active
automatiquement
en réaction aux signes aux produits par
les circonstances
il donne l'exemple des chiens et des
chats qui parce qu'ils ne réfléchissent
pas à leur action
gratte la terre sans finalement
ensevelir leurs excréments
ainsi cette perspective mécaniste
apporterait la preuve de l'infériorité
animal
on peut encore justifié la distinction
radicale de l'humanité et de l'animalité
en démontrant la supériorité de l'être
humain
si les animaux ne sont que des machines
perfectionner le mécanisme ne pourrait
en revanche suffit à expliquer la vie
humaine
un homme doit donc avoir quelque chose
de plus seulement son corps a lui aussi
rappelle le fonctionnement d'un automate
articuler la preuve de sa supériorité
tiendrait par conséquent à la
spécificité de son esprit pour les
stoïciens par exemple l'homme a une
place privilégiée dans la nature parce
que lui seul possède une âme à
rationnelle comment explique-t-il dans
leur cosmologie détail diogène laërce
exposé général des doctrines stoïcienne
l'âme du monde est un souffle qui se
répand inégalement dans l'univers pour
assurer la cohésion de la matière
lorsqu'il est peu puissants ils créent
les êtres inanimé lorsqu'il est un peu
plus les végétaux au troisième degré il
constitue l'âme des animaux au quatrième
degré enfin ils engendrent l'âme
rationnelle des hommes
cette spécificité rang ceci capable de
vivre selon la perception du bien et du
mal tandis que les animaux sont eux
privés de raison tel serait l'origine de
la supériorité humaine l'idée de la
distinction radicale de l'humanité et de
l'animalité paraît donc de prime abord
confirmer tant par le fait que par la
théorie
à y regarder de plus près cependant
cette idée ne mérite peut-être pas le
crédit de l'évidence
agissante et pensant avec le préjugé de
leur supériorité sur les bêtes les
humains ont tendance à nier la part
d'animalité qui les anime ne leur en
déplaise l'animal ressemble à l'homme en
de nombreux points
pourquoi l'oubli t-il 7 au moins pour
partie les faits du biais de
confirmation il ne trouve que les
différences parce qu'ils cherchent les
différences pour confirmer leur croyance
en leurs supériorités qu'il cherche donc
les points communs et la distinction
leur apparaîtra probablement moins
radicale le corps humain on l'a vue
répond également à des automatismes
l'esprit humain est tout autant
susceptibles de conditionnement
montaigne estime que c'est la vanité qui
rend les hommes aveugle à ces vérités
s'ils abandonnent leurs préjugés sur les
bêtes et s'il les observe bien ils
réaliseront la profonde parenté qui unit
tous les êtres vivants nous vivons
écrit-il
eux c'est une nous sous un même toit et
respirons un maire
il y a plus ou moins entre nous une
perpétuelle ressemblance essai
multipliant les exemples le philosophe
souligner les propriétés communes aux
animaux et aux hommes
la malice l'ingéniosité la communication
l'anticipation l'organisation de la vie
collective ou encore la propension à
aller contre la nature
l'animalité et l'humanité serait en
réalité inextricable et pour cause
l'homme et l'animal aurait la même
origine cette hypothèse contredit les
discours légitime at her de la
supériorité humaine lesquels imagine au
contraire des origines différentes à
sapiens et aux bêtes
peut-être les récits mythologiques ou
religieux qui à l'instar de la genèse
confère à l'homme un statut exceptionnel
parmi les êtres vivants et une relation
privilégiée avec la divinité dès la
création du monde peut être ces récits d
origine traduit style eux aussi le
préjugé de la distinction radicale de
l'humanité et de l'animalité la
perspective évolutionniste elle infirme
ce préjugé
elle révèle que la proximité de sapiens
avec les autres espèces et en raison de
la sélection naturelle et de la lutte
pour la vie bien plus grande qu'on ne le
croit darwin explique en effet dans
l'origine des espèces que toutes les
espèces évoluent de la même manière
elles changent progressivement parce que
leur individus mute pour s'adapter à
leur milieu cette théorie inscrits
l'homme dans l'ensemble de la dynamique
du vivant elle invite également à
reconnaître en remontant les
modifications successives de l'évolution
que son espèce et les espèces animales
possède des ancêtres communs
la radicalité de la distinction entre
l'homme et l'animal serait aussi
illusoire à l'échelle collective on
souligne volonté que les sapiens ont
développé une grande capacité de
coopération
ce qui leur permettent d'organiser
efficacement leurs communautés en
particulier les subtilités de la
communication humaine rendrait possible
la compétition pacifique pour le pouvoir
et le consentement des membres du groupe
à l'autorité la vie politique des
sociétés humaines n'aurait pas
d'équivalent dans le monde animal
mais est-ce bien certain franz dévale
pense que l'homme n'est pas le seul
animal politique la politique du
chimpanzé ayant analysé les dynamiques
sociales des chimpanzés des bonobos il
affirme que les racines de la politique
sont plus anciennes que l'humanité en
effet il a observé que l'évolution de la
hiérarchie obéit à des lois similaires
chez ces hominidés et chez les sapiens
l'accession au pouvoir tient en dernière
instance à la constitution de la
coalition la plus puissante
le primatologue a même retrouvé chez les
singes des symboles politiques
prétendument humains comme le fait pour
un individu à la conquête du pouvoir de
montrer l'importance qu'il accorde aux
membres les plus jeunes du groupe les
communautés humaines ressemblerait donc
bien aux communautés animales
[Musique]
à ce stade de la réflexion l'idée de la
distinction radicale de l'humanité et de
l'animalité a perdu son crédit initial
faut-il pour autant en déduire que
l'homme est un animal comme un autre
[Musique]
s'il y a de l'animal en l'homme sans
qu'on ne puisse toutefois les confondre
c'est peut-être que l'humanité est une
destination et non pas une propriété ine
cette hypothèse est cohérente avec la
nature évolutive de l'être humain dans
cette perspective l'homme serait plus
proche des bêtes dans les premiers
stades de son existence puis il pourrait
s'élever à la dignité de sa nature dans
les stades suivant au fur et à mesure
qu'il prend conscience de sa spécificité
ne comparons pas la spontanéité de
l'enfant à celle de l'animal ne citons
pas communément la sagesse au grand âge
la noblesse propre à la nature humaine
peut ainsi apparaître comme une conquête
de l'esprit rousseau affirme que l'homme
s'est progressivement éloigné de sa
condition animale
je cite au lieu qu'un animal et au bout
de quelques mois
ce qu'il sera toute sa vie et son espèce
au bout de milan ce qu'elle était la
première année de ses mille ans discours
sur l'origine de l'inégalité
pour le philosophe seul l'homme possède
la perfectibilité la faculté qui
permettent de développer d'autres
facultés elle le rend tout
particulièrement capable de s'élever
spirituellement en prenant conscience
d'une part de sa liberté de résister au
commandement de la nature et d'autre
part de la mort il aurait donc par là le
potentiel d'accéder à sa dignité propre
[Musique]
mais l'humanité comme destination serait
plus précisément un projet s'éloigner de
l'animal jusqu'à sont distingués
radicalement cela ne serait contenu qu
en puissance dans la nature humaine
rien pas même le passage du temps ne
garantirait que l'homme ne développe sa
noblesse propres le dépassement de
l'animalité demanderait un effort il
s'agit de stimuler et d'orienter la
capacité de l'être humain à se
perfectionner
tel est l'enjeu fondamental de
l'éducation estime quand contrairement à
l'animal qui vit exclusivement par
l'instant l'être humain peut se
perfectionner vers une destination qu'il
a choisi si la discipline tir l'enfant
de l'animalité il ne faut pas pour
autant le dresser comme une bête car il
doit comprendre les principes dont
dérive ses actions le but n'est pas de
soumettre les hommes en devenir mais de
perfectionner l'espèce humaine dans son
ensemble c'est dans le problème de
l'éducation écrit quand que j le grand
secret de la perfection de la nature
humaine réflexion sur l'éducation
l'éducation et donc la responsabilité
d'une génération à l'égard de la
suivante elle signifie que l'être humain
peut dépasser l'animalité en se
perfectionnant lui même de sa propre
initiative
il est enfin possible de transposer
cette idée à l'échelle collective
peut-être les communautés humaines
pourrait-elle elle aussi évolué rsa mais
lloret continûment jusqu'à ne plus
ressembler aux communautés animales en
quoi surpasseront tel ou sur pastel déjà
une horde de loups où une tribu de st
jean
il semble pourtant que les défauts des
communautés animales n'est pas disparu
des communautés humaines
la rivalité l'inégalité l'injustice et
la violence ne sont pas des fantômes
pour youval noah harari la différence
fondamentale ne réside pas là
la distinction radicale entre l'humanité
et l'animalité tiendrait en réalité à la
taille des collectivités dans les
communautés d'animaux avance l'historien
la coopération se limite à une échelle
réduite
les proches parents en général sinon le
groupe se scinde inévitablement en
sous-groupes chez les humains en
revanche la fiction rend possible la
coopération à grande échelle
je cite toute coopération humaine à
grande échelle
qu'il s'agisse d'un état moderne d'une
église médiévale d'une cité antique ou
d'une tribu archaïque s'enracine dans
des mythes commun qui n'existe que dans
l'imagination collective sapiens
c'est le langage supérieur des sapiens
qui leur permet de créer une double
réalité grâce à laquelle ils peuvent se
perfectionner collectivement
l'homme n'aime pas qu'on le confonde
avec l'animal de fait il semble se
définir lui même par son rapport aux
bêtes
il leur serait par essence supérieure
force est de constater qu'ils les domine
depuis plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'années ce qui lui paraît conforme à
l'infériorité de la nature animale comme
à l'imminence de sa nature à lui mais
l'idée de la distinction radicale de
l'humanité et de l'animalité
mérite-t-elle tout son crédit
l'homme peut difficilement nier les
ressemblances qui le rapproche de
l'animal leur probable comme une origine
ou encore la similarité des logiques qui
animent leurs communautés respectives
ces éléments attestent certes qu'il y
aurait de l'animalité en l'homme
cependant il invalide pas totalement le
présupposé contenus dans l'énoncé et si
l'humanité était une destination une
finalité puisqu'il a la faculté de se
perfectionner
l'être humain pourrait s'en servir pour
s'élever individuellement et
collectivement à une dignité supérieur
qui reléguerait vraiment l'animal mais
aussi l'homme ordinaire dans l'animalité
[Musique]
oh